[cow mooing]
NARRATOR: Each year after the
harvest, the people of Thebes
held a celebration of the
dead called the "Beautiful
Festival of the Valley."
They carried statues of
Thebes' three main gods
in a grand procession
out of Karnak
temple east of the river.
[music playing]
They crossed the Nile in
ceremonial boats following
the sun's journey from the East
Bank, the land of the living,
to the West, the
land of the dead.
The procession ended at
the tombs and temples
on the West Bank,
where people had laid
offerings, including
pots of food
at the graves of the deceased.
[music playing]
[interposing voices]
The ritual ensured the dead
had provisions for eternity.
These pots mean a tomb
should be very close.
[interposing voices]
The roughly carved
casket appears to be
buried in a miniature tomb.
This is clearly no king,
but it's a vital clue
that he might be near.
If the burial does
predate Amunhotep I,
it proves Dra' Abu el-Naga' was
a cemetery by the time he died.
So he could be buried here.
But there's no way to tell
until this coffin is out
of the ground.